Okay.
So the Pharaoh was pretty impressed by
this dream interpretation and pretty
worried about it.
And I guess he's a reasonable person
despite the fact that he put Joseph in
jail.
Uh,
I guess he didn't have much choice.
Now therefore let Pharaoh look for a man
discreet and wise and set him over the
land of Egypt.
Let Pharaoh do this and let him appoint
officers over the loud.
This is what Joseph is saying,
and take up the fifth part of the land
of Egypt in the seven plenteous years
and let them gather all the food of
those good years that come and lay up
corn under the hand of Pharaoh and let
them keep food in the cities
and just like that Joseph has restored
to his position.
So Pharaoh said unto Joseph,
I am Pharaoh and without these shall no
man lift up his hand or foot in all of
the land of Egypt.
And so he comes out of the prison and he
really,
in some sense,
as far as I'm concerned,
he actually occupies a position that's
higher than the position of the Pharaoh.
It depends on how you look at it.
Because the Pharaoh is relegated himself
to ceremonial status,
right?
Joseph has all the responsibility,
makes all the decisions.
So defacto he's the Pharaoh.
He doesn't get the glory precisely,
although he's not doing too bad for
himself,
not,
there's a lesson in that too.
Um,
I wrote these rules for Quora a long
time ago and one of them,
I have written them into this,
some of them into this book you guys go
to a pamphlet about today.
One of the rules that I didn't write
about was
note that responsive note,
that opportunity lurks where
responsibility has been abdicated,
which is really interesting,
I think.
I mean,
I've seen people in their jobs,
they say things like,
well,
my,
the guy I work with doesn't do any work.
It's like,
well,
you could do it.
I mean,
I know there's limits to that,
but one of the things you can do at work
is make yourself indispensable.
I mean,
you might get the cane types against you
if you do that,
but there's something to be said for
being indispensable because when people
start to be dispensed with,
you've probably won't be one of them.
Or even if you are,
then the fact that you're indispensable
just means you can go somewhere else and
be indispensable.
They're not.
It's just as useful.
So it's very,
very difficult to permanently put down
someone who's really good at doing
things because they can just go off and
do them somewhere else.
And one of the ways that you get like
that is to take responsibility when
someone else is failing to do so.
And you think,
well,
I shouldn't have to do that.
That's one way of thinking about it.
Another way of thinking about it is,
oh good,
I get to do that.